Oh
[Music]
whose gain was then another coma who's
that fat guy you're in love with stop
moving stop moving I'm working here now
I get why George W Bush only paints dogs
you want to be more like George W Bush
he's like America's worst president oh
not even close anymore
he's actually pretty beloved he's like
America's grandpa right now Bill Cosby
is America's grandpa not according to
the 60 women who accused him of rape
look stop moving 60 women what oh my god
well I hope he spends time in jail like
that other rapist Mike Dyson that bitch
can't iron Mikes number one he had this
great Broadway show he's a real tell
he's in the hangover he knocked up the
fat guy Mike Tyson top moving next
you're gonna tell me we love OJ Simpson
no we just let him out of jail the juice
is loose he had a great year last year
they shot a show about him oh what a
bunch of Emmys hey Shawn documentary and
it won the Oscar Oscar Moore documentary
what Johnny Depp doesn't even have an
Oscar but no I can't say a bad word
about Johnny Depp bad-boy free smokes in
size way older they look sad
shut the up okay shut up I just
want to wear my Aaron Hernandez jersey
it calms me down what or is it you mean
this
you mean this why is that all ripped off
because he returned Ennis he's a
murderer
no he burned a bunch of people including
himself family move too much
[Music]
hey guys turns out this country doesn't
like sick people anymore so you have to
leave now they're already dead even
better
you